6 44. welcome back a new Art Exhibit  inside Las Vegas city hall is now open  this month is human trafficking  awareness month and the new exhibit  showcases the artwork created by human  trafficking survivors each flower  painted symbolizes the future they hope  blooms for themselves  when someone can see something like this  so beautiful with with with you know a  story behind it that they can be  inspired to know that healing is  possible when these victim survivors  learn to tap into their true power and  find purpose in everything that's  happened to them  Nevada has the second highest rate of  human trafficking in the country the Art  Exhibit opened to the public located on  the second floor of the city hall  building  all right take oh look if you haven't  been driving around town saying this it  looks alive now